the man has a way with women i think we
know this guy
who what is happening
oh
oh the master
get out of town what is a nicer he looks
like hitman
our man's moved up in the world oh he's
got the suit on
it's got you in the suit
my friend
jake locker
let's go
wow what an ending i i gotta see
everything else jake did like show a
second season
just the jake lockley cut from
everything
give us the jake cut release it we know
you're happy
well welcome back to new rockstars we
just finished watching moon night series
finale or should we say season finale
because this post-credits scene finally
introduces us to jake lockley mark
spector's additional alter from the
comics jake from state harm
he's normally a new york cabby in this
case a spanish-speaking cabbie
i love how they play into uh oscar
isaac's roots and um giving us a little
explanation behind that song choice at
the end of last episode uh but so much
of his story remains untold like
how much of jake did we actually see on
this series where did he come from where
did he go where did he come from
white people go crazy over that cotton
idea
but what is conscious relationship with
mark and his altars now and uh by the
way in this episode what happened to
those kaiju size god
where's the megazord when you need it i
mean like we needed a whole like
megazord man like that would have been
really cool
this is inside marvel it's new rockstars
moon night reaction show i'm eric boss
my easter egg breakdown of this final
episode or the season finale episode is
coming tomorrow to the channel but here
with me to react to this episode to try
to answer your biggest questions is mt
mt thoughts on this finale this finale
was great i mean i love this finale a
lot i love seeing layla kick and butt
like very much uh like captain america
style with her wings she's like all
right i'm here and like like she looked
really cool and like and i'm assuming
that she's the scarlet scarab now now
that she has that like big old red
scarab brought on her chest yes i think
that's been confirmed by marvel yeah
it's been confirmed by marvel just not
in the episode
um so yeah like i really dug this and i
love seeing kanchu fight i didn't think
we'd see kanchu actually fight at any
point during the season so like seeing
him throw hands was really cool yeah i
think after last episode um my bed was
made for this season i was really happy
with the the directions they took mark
and steven's character i like how they
focused on the two of them as a core
dramatic relationship with the series
and i love seeing them come to terms
with each other throughout each episode
uh so i was really happy with where this
uh this season ended i i think some
people might have some mixed reactions
to this finale that tends to be the case
with a lot of these marvel disney plush
shows is uh they just have like a lot of
things to tie up and sometimes the
either the pacing of the episode or the
narrative shortcuts that are taken just
to get characters from a to b just make
people feel like wait what's happening
here but i think that's just a result of
the way these shows are structured and
the way they're shot and the way they're
written as uh kind of six chapter films
uh as a result instead of like you know
with most other most other shows the
season finale is a really uh focused on
hour of television that is meant to like
have its own kind of lovely arc from the
first scene to the final scene and
that's not always the case with these
marvel disney plush shows overall i felt
really satisfied at the end of the show
i i
loved this season this whole season uh i
loved the journey and i loved how much
we learned i feel like looking back on
ourselves you know two months ago
there's so much about d.i.d and
egyptology that i was very ignorant too
and now my eyes have been opened to
a whole new world of characters and and
people and and human experience and i'm
really really grateful to the series for
taking us down that path
like no for real like just like you said
like i learned so much about d.i.d and
like you know different altars and how
altars manifest like i love when like
disney and in marvel
give us content that like helps us grow
as people and like the moon knight
really did that for me so
hats off to you disney yeah well let's
uh talk about what happened this episode
so the finale episode opens with mark's
corpse back in the tomb and harrow takes
amitsuhapti using it to upgrade his
staff into a single-headed croc axe
right i mean this kind of it just looks
like the the the dangling staff was not
enough we just needed one croc i thought
that was an interesting evolution right
from uh what seemed to be a visage of uh
ahmet saying i'm gonna try to be fair uh
and be two-minded and look at both sides
of your soul to just being an aggressive
devourer
with an axe on the back of his head
hey i mean like harrow does have an axe
to grind so hey there you go it's
perfect symbolism
uh now layla's just uh very successfully
snooping around the shadows of this tomb
taking out one of the guards very
quickly and very uh
quietly uh putting on their robes it
seems like harrow can hear layla i kind
of read this as harrow doesn't really
care at that point because he's like i
got what i came for she's not gonna be
able to stop like i don't know if you
ever played uh the first spider-man ps4
game but uh it's sort of like the mary
jane missions where mary jane just
sneaks around like really good i'm like
how are you this good at seeking around
dangerous people
because the script needs her to be empty
she's gotta get back there to break open
that new shopkin we don't have time for
her to get pinned down which is clearly
out matched in this room and then she uh
tags along with all them on a ride back
through the desert to this checkpoint i
like how they're clearly down to single
digits after these heka priests have
been wiping them out uh but they're like
wait um was she one of us to begin with
i can't really tell i didn't really get
to know everyone in the cult they just
told us to go come out here and dig and
i hopped on the first flight i we didn't
do the name thing we should have done
we should introduce one fact about
ourselves that would that would have
really helped yes
okay then at the checkpoint hero uses a
staff to send these soldier souls to the
duat now i'm assuming these were the
souls that uh mark stephen and tuareg
saw dropping into the dunes last episode
it didn't seem like a whole lot of them
there was what maybe 10 or 12. um now
later in the episode they suck a lot of
the souls to to feed ahmet as she grows
but that happens after mark has already
left the aru and reconnected with
stephen and the dua to come back into
the world of living so i just want to
know where all those souls were maybe
there were some other checkpoints maybe
this was the fifth of uh of like 10
checkpoints that they were going through
and lots of souls got sent to the duat
but i liked how they floated up from
their bodies because like i would
imagine that they dropped down but it
just kind of implies that the duat is
another uh space of being and it's
really kind of beyond where we are um
one of my favorite moments of the
episode where it begins using the
corpses of these soldiers to communicate
with layla but i love how much
it gives these actors a chance to just
like do their best and tony has to leave
impression it was just really fun to see
all the actors get together imagine like
at the end of end game tony stark just
became tomorrow he's like hey everybody
it's okay he's fine he's in heaven
[Laughter]
so they return to the great pyramid
where uh hero uses his staff to slay the
any ad we don't really see this happen
like many of the big fights in this
episode it just happens off screen um
and they release amit back into her
amazing crocodile form i think ahmet
looked great this episode like the cg
was really i love the design the mummy
wrappings dangling from her snout uh the
characterization of vomit really really
cool in this episode i kind of wish that
she looked more like king k rool from
the donkey kong series but i'll take it
i'll take it
you've been saying that about a lot of
characters
i say that about layla when i first met
her i was like come on not not the not
the real figure that i wanted for uh
mark's love interest but i'll i'll take
it i guess
you said that about me you said that all
of a sudden
i wish you when i first met eric i was
like ah no no crocodile form no crown
not king k rool
[Laughter]
so leila frees konchu and uh khanshu
fights ahmet the kanchu ahmet fights in
this episode pretty cool very much
enjoyed them yes i really loved seeing
kanchi throw hands yeah it was great uh
and then a meanwhile mark returns to the
duo to be with stephen we get this sweet
anna elsa moment where they both hold
the same heart at the same time and
osiris's gates mercifully open reverting
the uh from the sand back to flesh
that was great it was sweet i love
seeing the two of them connect it's guy
love between two guys homie never heard
about guy love it's magical uh help me
out with something empty what was this
big uh sand wave that was about to it
was that just like the nature that you
want saying you cannot leave us
that is uh a violation of our way
like what was it like when that was
happening i first at first i thought i
was like oh my god are we about to get
marvel zombies like are we about to see
a bunch of zombies come through this
portal and like we're about to get like
a whole mess of nonsense but like i
think that yeah i think like like you
were just saying it this is just the
duat way of being like hey where are you
going like you are sand so like you
can't leave us like you are the duat so
like the duo's trying to reclaim the
sand that's trying to leave yeah no but
when i love to let that osiris open the
doors and be like all right you can go
it's fine he's a soft ape i would have
loved to have seen osiris weigh in on
this i thought we're going to get like a
conversation between tawarat and osiris
because i between last steps on this
episode i feel like audiences needed
more information about what these gates
were and how exactly they worked and and
was there someone at these gates was it
osiris's godly form was it his avatar
who was just like uh cranking a lever to
open them or something i'd i just would
have liked to have just getting a bit
more context just so that we understood
the stakes of uh of like what he needed
to see to melt his heart instead all we
got was this line from toronto saying
he's a softie
okay
but who is a softy we never met osiris
on the show we just met him talking
through his avatar but like it would
have been great to have seen osiris
godly form making these choices and so
we got this confusing wave of sand that
like
to where it was suddenly she was hopping
around all over the place like she was
in the aru and then she's back on the
boat and then she steers the boat into
the wave that prevents it from crashing
on them is that how waves work wouldn't
the sand just go around the boat and
flood them why isn't it these sand
zombies that are dragging them back into
the sand why is it now suddenly
like we didn't see the dunes move around
we they were kind of static
you didn't see sandman he was in the
back oh i missed it
i missed it let's go into the breakdown
look oh here we are again we're in a
finale of a disney plus show where
everyone's like god i wish eric will
just stop reviewing these shows because
he's so mean to them he's so mean look i
just said i love this show everyone i'm
just yes we do going through my points
of confusion this is a little bit of a
confusing moment i'm allowed to have a
mixed bag of opinions and still overall
like things
it's okay it doesn't deny your 100
approval of this show it's great if you
loved it awesome i loved it too i just
didn't love everything in it it's all
right but um
anyway so mark and steven come back to
life and they make this deal with koncho
i love this moment where it's he's
talking to both of them and it's not
chaotic they're making a choice where
they get to hand off oh you get to
appear as mr night now i'm going to bear
his moon night ceremony look here we're
going to have this conversation with
kahn together and now i think that was
great layla connects with tuaret who
takes her as a temporary avatar and
gives her a new suit the scarlet scarab
confirmed now it's never named in this
episode but marvel.com has said that it
is a scarlet scarab you should be able
to tell from the scarlet scarab logo and
the fact that her wings are like scared
of wings and she's got the little scarab
like arms or things you know the pincers
or whatever those things are uh and her
name of course laila abdullah alfa lily
and she had the little scarlet scarab uh
bandage on her thing at honor at the end
of episode four so uh yeah this is a
major character from uh well not a major
character kind of a lesser known
character from the invaders comics but i
like how they they change it from being
a villain uh which
scarlet scarab was to the invaders their
name is the invaders which includes like
human torch and
uh and who else uh bucky i think is part
of that uh yeah
not a not a great group to be called in
today's day and age
but now she they get to reown it as like
the first egyptian mcu superhero which i
think that's really fun
i love this trajectory for her character
i can't wait to see her more in the mcu
hopefully like i really hope that we see
her more like and she's not like a side
character's like all right this is just
for moonlight no like integrate her
aboard to the mcu i want to see her more
yeah this is exciting and now harrow
unleashes on its judgment all over cairo
so that new disciples are just judging
everyone their souls feed into ahmed and
making her grow giant sizes
because uh biggest power ranger is
heightening let's go
to big boys
i thought it was really fun i kept
wondering like do average people right
now see this fight right because
like we didn't they couldn't see konshu
before only mark could see conscious
they couldn't see the jackal so are they
just seeing like
dust billowing around the uh around the
pyramids and the sphinx it seems like
layla is able to see them but i think
layla has tauara it's power so i'm
wondering if like average people the mcu
do not see these giant god kaiju
fighting yeah which is really but it's
also weird because like layla did see
um kanchu before she was like she made
that deal with talari so like i wonder
what that deal is i think it was konchu
speaking to her
like that was like a choice by khan shoe
to make himself visible to her for
everyone else who kanchu is not
addressing i think they just see like a
trash can getting kicked over you know
yeah um i would have just loved a shot
cutting to a random cairo citizen
looking up and just seeing like
why is the ground shaking so much
i think's going to tip over what's going
on is there a desert storm happening
what
um just to give us a frame of reference
because i think that would have been
like a really fun choice you know the
way that ant-man cuts away from the epic
stakes of the thomas the uh tank engine
battle just to remind us that this is
like a torch
that's like a little bit of a con
contextual ship there would have been
fun um
but we see this battle fight on two
different planes you have the the gods
fighting uh with um mark in their avatar
fighting on the ground level which is
such like a classic greek thing right
you have the the two tiers of the battle
you have the gods disputing with the
mortal conflict using them as uh as
their avatar as their surrogates as
their proxies so i i just loved the the
staging of all this of the two tears um
and uh right as harrow seems to have
mark pinned he blacks out awakens with
everybody dead and harrow pinned and
presumably this is well this is
definitely
jake tcob once again taking care oh
business
but we don't see it happen we never see
it happen
we just assumed that
he was really good
this is this uh stocky cabbie like
literally jake is just like all right uh
you guys are in trouble i've got this
like he's the problem solver he's like
anything that you need done it'll get
taken care of but you won't remember it
and conscie won't tell you that's what
i'm saying like the most active of these
three
i gotta see this active character do his
thing let's do it i wanna know i don't
know everything he did i wanna see a
whole episode where he's just
making moves on dylan just that process
of action right like to show me how to
how to get it done because i don't know
how to flirt with girls show me jake
show me lockly show me the lockley
technique teach us
i hope it's better than dennis don't uh
i i tried dennis it's not it's not good
it's not a good technique uh don't do it
so mark and layla use the spell they
somehow know the words to to shrink
ahmet down into harrow's mouth mark
refuses to execute harrow and demands
con to release them which he does kinda
not really though we then see stephen
and mark back in harrow's office from
last episode uh one last moment of
self-doubt that they must overcome and
then back in bed with the same music as
episode one same foot harness but now
two goldfish in the tank why are they
back in the harness well the
post-credits scene shows harrow in a
psychiatric hospital seeing a cup of
coffee as sand
putting him in the perspective of mark
spector someone who doesn't really know
what his reality is and then he's
wheeled out by a spanish-speaking jake
lockley who shoves in the back of his
limo with a plate reading spectre while
a suited conscious introduces them and
then jake shoots arrow with a sniper
pistol before driving off toward london
now this ending a post-credits scene is
where we will start our discussion of
this finale episode
it's one that leaves us with many
questions we're going to try to address
the big ones in this episode but don't
forget to check out rockstarsmerch.com
to grab our latest succession shirt tomb
of the moon god before ahmet comes and
swallows it up for good once it's gone
from the night sky it is gone for good
you can find that latest obsession shirt
along with all of our moon night
inspired merch over at new
rockstarsmirch.com
and when you get one of those shirts
whatever one of our latest session is
you'll get to write in a custom shout
out that will appear at the bottom of
inside marvel mikel says
how do you think moon knight will fit
into the rest of the mcu well i hope
we'll see him in uh werewolf by night
later this year
i mean
it's time for the midnight suns yeah man
like werewolf by night was a big part
like where was by night and moon night
are really big parts of each other in
terms of like origin stories so like
yeah i could definitely see mark showing
up in werewolf by night for sure uh but
like
sun moon night suns uh but yeah midnight
suns is definitely where we're gonna see
him next or at some point anyway uh matt
says the stone hearts are just bloodless
hearts called ghost hearts they aren't
stone
interesting interesting i i would go
with you matt if uh if the texture of
that heart was just a bit different it
seemed obviously it was probably cast
out of plastic as a movie prop but it
didn't it wasn't squishy
even if there was no blood in it it
would be a it'd have some give to it it
would have some give uh or if it was a
ghost start it would at least just float
just make it a vfx orb right but i don't
know i'll defer to you you seem to know
more about this man adam says i love you
guys listen all the time and my fiance
hates your voice eric lol well adam
thank you for uh watching slash
listening to us all the time but um
maybe maybe give uh
a second thought to this fiance
maybe she's not the one
maybe she's not the one adam
maybe your wife i think about it
need better taste huh have you thought
about that
your fiancee or me adam
just saying i hate to make you choose
you gotta choose your fiance or me
you can't have us both
you can't have us both
eric's packing his stuff up
to the left to the left
all right
empty uh what's our question coming out
of this finale hi bro what the fish just
happened in this moonlight finale we
gotta talk about it yeah okay so this
post credit scene confirmed that each of
the times mark or stephen blacked out to
find uh extreme violence and carnage
around him that was jake jake lockley
being the uh the third alter of mark
spector steven grant in the comics uh
known as being a new york taxi driver in
this show changed to be a spanish
speaking uh deadly assassin limo driver
now we don't know if he always drives a
limo uh or this is just a gig the way it
was for old man logan in the logan movie
uh or he kind of almost seems like a
james bond henchman right he seems like
odd job or something like that like a
deadly uh almost cartoony villain but
awesome see i love
like they they don't really show it on
screen but he's totally winning over
that nurse who's like um you just want
to wheel him out of here and he's like i
got it love and like he does something
to her face and you see her hands just
kind of awkwardly be like oh um hey man
girls love accents man i don't know what
it is just this is an accent mt he's
speaking spanish and she must know
spanish or he did something uh to just
be like i don't know what you were
saying but i like the way you're saying
it sir you wield this patient please
have one of our patients as
as a courtesy
it seems like it kills a few orderlies
too would you like to take some other
now um the times that we have seen jake
this season obviously the final fight of
this episode the somehow he overcame
harrow um which i just want to know
exactly how he did it because mark had
the power of moon night i want to know
what jake's moon night form was
cause we saw what stephen's moon knight
forum was right we saw what mark's moon
knight form was what did it look like
when jake did it and what uh additional
abilities were unlocked to get him out
of that pinned position because every
time this happened he was not in a good
spot he must have been he must have had
some nifty toys to get out of this spot
and this includes the thugs on the roof
in episode three they were stabbed uh he
wasn't even on the roof to begin with he
was like knocked out down on the bizarre
level so yeah yeah
it's some vicious moves um now
interestingly the previous leon showed
us the red sarcophagus so that was
almost certainly jake right i don't
think we have any doubts about that uh
he might have even been the one who
brutally killed all those heroes
soldiers in the alpine village in
episode one because mark didn't seem
like the kind of guy who would kill
people that savagely that seems to be a
jake move like the fact that martin was
still so guilty over killing those
archaeologists i i don't know if he
would kill all those i think he would
just
maybe self-defense uh take some people
down but then get out of there oh yeah
and like it makes sense because like
mark would have also went directly for
harrow um and like you know got him so
like if it was jake jake would just
wanna jake usually deals with the threat
the immediate threat at hand and then
leaves so like it makes sense for that
to be jake for sure obviously it was
jake who slayed dylan in the museum but
i want to know did he ask her out in
spanish did he use spin does dylan know
spanish did dylan just think he was
doing a bit to woo or was it a
non-verbal asking out so dylan's like
this is just a multilingual guy who
works in the gift shop yeah in season
two i want jake to
get dylan like to finally like seal the
deal at some point get get the date down
because he he wanted the date let's just
make sure that jake gets his date yeah i
mean we know jake is a carnivore the man
likes steak he picked the steak
restaurant he did not care that steven's
vegan he's eating and honestly didn't
really care it seems like jake was the
most aware of all these alters over what
the context of this was had a deeper
layer of a connection with kanchu than
even mark did so it's it's pretty
interesting to think back on all the
times that jake intentionally chose
chaos and violence in his relationship
with his altars
not really caring about what uh where
stephen would wake up or mark would wake
up
even though that would
spell some confusion and some
complication for him and for what kancho
wanted him to do the guy has kind of a
reckless abandon that i really love and
i would love to explore more in at least
another episode or like i i i love this
post credit scene i just wish that that
wasn't a final reveal i understand that
this this show's relationship is with
stephen and mark and i think that's one
of the best things about it i just think
you could still introduce that wild card
in like the fifth or the sixth episode
and not affect that core relationship
he's just a guy who's like screwing up
the relationship he's the guy who's the
wedge between the two people who we care
you know like there's all kinds of ways
you can structure it um
and uh i just think it's like we end the
season with this james bond vibe as jake
uh
is revealed as the preferred number one
alter for khanshu and uh um it's such a
bold decision that though to never
really show exactly everything that
happened it like everything in the show
it's about like
uh leaving things a mystery it's also
building you guessing
yeah now mark and stephen continue to be
harnessed to their bed meaning that
conscious still occupying the body only
just moonlighting
as jake locklear continued to do his
bidding but now with conscious continue
to be bonded to this third altar moon
knight as a character does live on in
the mcu either for a second season maybe
a midnight sun's team up hopefully an
appearance in werewolf by night marvel
studios oscar isaac you gotta imagine
they want to keep this going hopefully
they do this has been a really fun ride
and it doesn't have to end here now just
to clear up some questions why is harrow
in a psychiatric hospital
is that possibly in his mind well uh
it's my take on this mt and tell me if
you disagree i think just mark and
stephen and layla maybe some criminal
justice authority in the mcu might have
decided arthur harrow with amit uh
connected with his mind is just kind of
certifiably you know ill
and
gets to be put kept in this psychiatric
hospital uh and maybe they had him like
extradited to london i just i would be
surprised that uh
egypt would allow that i feel like
because all those people in cairo are
they still dead
like hundreds of people in cairo there's
just corpses lining the streets
uh that one guy who climbed up atop the
great pyramid of giza seems to have
something to do with it
so
[Music]
i would imagine they would probably
hold him responsible for that but i
don't know maybe osiris the softie
opened his gates and all those people
got to come back to life i'm not really
sure but my thinking is that what we saw
in that mental hospital at the end with
harrow was real i think harrow is in
that hospital and i think he is dead now
i think he was shot and killed and then
that's like it's finally kanchu
executed on what he wanted to do uh
because otherwise it's like whose
perspective are we watching that scene
from
when the car drives away if it is like a
subjective distorted reality uh i i is
it from conscious perspective is it from
jake's perspective i think that was like
one of the few times in the series we
saw an objectively playing out scene
right i think harrow is dead now
yeah i mean like
most likely harrow is dead because like
you know he was murdered with the direct
guidance from kanchu like kanchu was
watching this man get murdered so like
let's say like for example because like
we do know that ahmet is in hero's body
so like potentially he could have the
same healing factor as mark has but we
know that kanchoo knows how to kill an
avatar in these situations so like
some like he's not gonna do a half-assed
job he wanted harrow dead this entire
time so harrow is for sure dead for sure
and like and also this was objective
reality because like i mean this was
true reality because of all the things
you said like at no point during the
season has harrow exhibited any signs of
like you know being mentally unwell or
projecting anything
so like you know i don't see why he
would have to be in any sort of other
reality or in his head so like yeah it
seems like it's actually happened let's
talk about mark and steven in these
final minutes why did they return to
harrow's office after concha releases
them like
i guess my thinking is that the office
was never part of the duat boat the
office was really a separate organizing
principle within mark's mind that
manifested his self-doubt it was kind of
a shared space between
between how his mind interpreted the
duod as a psychiatric hospital and how
his own mind trapped him inside of his
own mind to keep him from moving on so
the office is always independent from
the duat it's just in mark's mind yeah
uh it's like how is organizing principle
is self-doubt continues to try to uh to
prod him uh and i think that's why last
episode he would toggle back and forth
from the office to the other parts of
the boat hospital those were real i
think the other parts were the real duat
the office though was not real that was
the one part of the show that i think
was in mark's mind the the one setting i
should say in the show that was in
mark's mind uh and i think before he can
reach that true inner peace and
stability with stephen they must return
to that office to overcome that inner
version of harrow that their self-doubt
is manifested and for the first time we
see his feet as actually bleeding and i
think they i my take on this empty is
that they were always bleeding in the
show but steven or mark never saw them
that way until now when they no longer
see harrow as a threat what do you think
though yeah no i think that you know
that whole office sequence was just
mostly
symbolic of like you know like you said
like the the what mark was going through
on a on his mental level about the whole
situation and so like um when harrow
like his feet started bleeding when he
himself was was like really hurt and and
like about to die and so like i think
that it was just like all right you
defeated me so like i am now hurt and
like and like i'm dying so it's just
like it was all just mostly just
symbolic of
what mark was going inside and like it's
not really anything anything that
happened in that office is not really
meant to be taken
seriously as something that actually
happened in my opinion yeah i i think it
it's important to the characters
obviously into their character growth uh
but i don't think it represents like an
actual physical space that we could
visit somewhere in reality right
now realistically i think from that time
from the moment where conscious released
them in the tomb it might have actually
been jake who overtook the wheel at that
point and then it might even jacob made
that deal with layla to keep heroin at
psych hospital in london maybe a
concession to her and now
uh like the way that mark and steven
wake up in the flat uh it seems like
jake is keeping the two of them in the
flat the way that mark kept stephen in
the flat like it seems like they're now
kind of trapped in someone else's game
so i think steven has been so i think
jake has been making a lot of moves
behind the scenes and anytime like i
think even from the moment at the end of
episode two
when uh mark suddenly finds himself in
the hotel room in egypt i think that was
jake who got him there because it seems
like we we teleported from mark's point
of view
i think it must have been jake
um yeah so um i think ultimately the
conversation i want to have about this
is like are we reading all of this too
literally could there is there any
chance that the final scenes of this
episode or maybe the post-credits scene
might be taking place inside someone's
head i don't i don't think so because
that'd be a really weird way to end the
series like considering that you know
it's not all like the whole like this
whole series has not taken place in
mark's head or not even like the
majority of the series has taken place
in mark's head so like it would be kind
of weird for like that final really
impactful moment to be like all right
just kidding it was all just a goof um
but like you know yeah so i think it's
it's actually happening but yeah what do
you think yeah i i think uh everything
in this series we're meant to
question interpret that's kind of the
themes of the uh jeff lemire in
smallwood uh run of the comics
and
that's why they returned to that office
at the end i think they want us to kind
of question i think the fact that they
put
arthur harrow in a psychiatric hospital
as opposed to arthur harrow just like
back with his cult or as a homeless
person or trying to live a new life and
then he gets abducted or taken i i think
they want us to wonder wait was all of
this in arthur harrow's mind i think
that feeling the the questioning is
important of the show but i don't think
we're meant to arrive at specific
answers
that are
clearly defined in the final end of the
argument that it was definitely in his
mind um and i don't think that's the
case i think it is a stronger series and
a better story
if most of these details are things that
actually happened in the mcu including
the fact that alexander the great had a
crocodile avatar and that's what made
him great like there's all kinds of
crazy things
that got established it's canon in the
world of the mcu as a result of this
series and i love it i love when the mcu
takes big swings in these shows that
like
leave leave huge implications for the
world i think they need to be doing that
more
often honestly we need to have a whole
assassin's creed series just with the
avatars from different that would be
freaking dope i would love that marvel
get on it i love it
i love it and you know who i love this
episode our new scarlet scarab layla
yeah i wanna know how i wanna know what
happened to her at the end of this show
and where she'll where we'll see her
next but first we wanna thank helix
sleep for sponsoring this episode even
if you have magical armor that appears
out of nowhere to help you fight crime
you still need a good night's sleep on a
mattress made just for you well our
friends at helix mattress are here to
make sure you have that helix sleep is a
quiz that matches your body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down to sleep hot even
though helix plus mattress or plus size
sleepers i got a helix mattress and i
love it i know mt's got one too we're
both big fans the mattress ships right
to your door for free no need to go to a
mattress store just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside marvel also thanks
to bespoke for sponsoring this episode
this spring revamp your daily routine
with bespoke post in their new seasonal
lineup of must-have box of awesome
collections bespoke post partners with
small businesses and emerging brands to
bring you the most unique goods every
month no matter what you have going on
this season box of awesome has you
covered from camping gear essentials to
cookout must-haves like hot sauces and
bbq rubs box of awesome has collections
for every part of your life i also like
the scorch box which contains hot sauces
from all over the country that i can use
to spice up my meals to get started take
their quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories each box is valued
at around 70
but you only pay a fraction of that
price it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel any time get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code marvel at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code marvel for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
marvel and thanks to raycon for
sponsoring this episode this mother's
day spoil your mum with the gift of
quality premium wireless audio courtesy
of raycon raycon wireless earbuds are a
must-have for super moms with raycons
they can stay entertained listening to
their favorite podcasts or music plus
take phone calls with vivid voices
technology all hands-free recons are
user friendly for those moms who are
just switching to wireless earbuds easy
to set up easy to use and seamless
bluetooth pairing plus they come in a
bunch of fun color options so you can
find mom a color that suits her
personality in style with optimized gel
tips for the perfect in-ear fit these
earbuds are so comfortable and they will
not budge trust me for the mom on the go
raycons offer eight hours of playtime
and a 32-hour battery life with their
compact portable charging case they're
priced just right you get quality audio
at half the price of their other premium
audio brands and raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 49 000 five-star
reviews perfect for a five-star mom we
use raycons and new rockstars all the
time and we love the reliable battery
life and comfortable fit tell mom how
much you love her and make sure she
hears it in crystal clear audio quality
with raycon go to buy recon dot com
marvel to get 15 off your mother's day
order that's by raycon.com marvel all
right mt let's talk about our new
scarlet scarab in the mcu what happens
to her from the moment we cut away from
her in the tomb and what happens here at
the end of the series where do you think
she goes from here i have a feeling that
she is in egypt right now and because
like we did have that really great
moment of like that heard that a girl
saying are you a new egyptian superhero
and she was like yeah i guess i am and
uh because like if you think about it
every like the world is big and like
different parts of the world do you need
superheroes and like leila is probably
just
back at her homeland that she hasn't
been in in 10 years and just being like
all right i'm going to help out my
people which is really dope and like i'm
so excited that tawarit
is in the mcu like officially as like
with an avatar because i love her so
much she's one of my favorite mcu
characters and i want to see more of her
i'm very sad that she just didn't have a
hippo themed costume i was really open
for a hippo themed costume but uh
scarlet scarab is pretty cool what do
you think yeah i i mean
what i would love to see is like layla
showing up in like secret invasion or
you know one of these other shows armor
wars i don't know there's all kinds of
shows coming out on disney plus i just
don't know if it's gonna happen right
like monica rambo
we haven't seen her since one division
uh like we saw her uh we saw her mom we
think in the trailer
um but that's you know like it seems
like all these shows are kind of being
uh surprisingly produced independently
of each other and don't always have all
these plans for interconnectivity um but
i i think there are all kinds of places
for her to show up i just wanna i wanna
see her continue to do her thing um i
think it's probably too late for her to
show up in thor love and thunder uh
right yeah that'd be my guess yeah it's
way too late right there um if you if
they do an a force which i really want
marvel to do an a4s project
layla get her on the squad yeah i think
she'd fit right in there i mean she's
great a really really fun character you
know she is kind of like one of these
characters who's uh protecting a setting
that is not really seen enough in in
genres like this or in the mcu she'd be
a great person to show up in like black
panther wakanda forever like maybe we
have like
different countries not just on the
african continent but all around the
world where these places are protected
like these are protectors of lands that
have been plundered or have been
attacked over this over the millennia uh
she would be another great candidate i
think she would just have some an
interesting dynamic i'm glad she brought
that up because like we did get that
huge name drop and the last episode of
buschmann and buschmann in the comics
runs um the country of burunda at one
point which is a neighboring country to
wakanda they share a border so like
since bushman was name-dropped and he
does have that past and we do have this
egyptian superhero i would love to see
layla like being the first person like
to really confront bushmen and be like
yo what are you doing like i am a hero
here you can't really do this also
marvel if you haven't cast bushmen yet
call wayne brady wayne brady would kill
it as bushman just let he would be your
heath ledger joker he would be amazing
he's an amazing improv dude just let him
go crazy as bushman he would kill it
anyway sorry wow
hot take empty hot tape um i love it
love love me some wayne brady love me
something
anyway
i don't see it as bushmen but
you do
i love wayne brady i think i would love
to see layla go seek vengeance on
bushmen i think that needs to be her
next move is uh should we i i think if
she has reached this point of peace with
mark uh i think then she must believe
him that it was bushman who did this and
i think she needs to track this guy down
particularly and avenge
um you killed my father prepared to die
a quick question arthur harrow had this
interesting line where he said that his
we learned that his scales were
imbalanced and he thought that his
service of ahmed could be his penance
for what do you think arthur harrow was
serving as penance what what is his
backstory i mean i i assume that there
was all because of his service to his
conscience for loving um murdering those
people because he doesn't admit to khan
shuzu shakti that like he loved it and
like he he did it for himself really and
while he was doing it in service to
kanchu so i think that it was his um his
his love of murder and like his love of
harming other people
that he was like sort of guilty for it
was like that's why he walked on these
little super sharp glass all the time
and she was like i feel guilty so like i
want to
serve my penance and that's why he was
like yo um ahmed if you need to kill me
do it because like i it's all fair it's
fair is fair like i did this whole thing
because i
thought that bad people needed to go
from the world and if i'm bad to you
then you know i'm not going to argue
because i did some pretty terrible
things um but yeah so you think that his
enjoyment of this process was the sin
that he was
that's the thing that he felt guilty for
and like he hates um konchu for abusing
him into that scenario where he now has
this this burden on him where like and
now i know that i love to be a an
abusing person so like you sort of made
me like you can't you um which is sort
of
you know
sad in its own way it is sad
i read it as he has some dark past that
we still don't know that he did
something to bring him to this place i
mean there's still so much about arthur
herrera's past this show never answered
right true how he got to this point it's
not like every character needs to have a
whole episode that gives us a flashback
to how they got but a line of dialogue
maybe
like all we all we know about his past
is that he claimed to have been
conscious past
uh avatar i don't know if that's true or
not but he seems to know a lot about
khan shu maybe that's stuff that like
ahmet told him about and his connections
with he didn't seem to have a direct
communication though with amit i just
want to know how he got to that place
right or if he was actually conscious
avatar because kanchu was
in that
statue when mark found him so
did harold put him back in there i i
just have a lot of questions
uh about arrow and that's why i want to
see a second season of this or for some
of these things to come back and some
other series i don't know i don't know
what was cut from this show but like i
we never learned some critical things
and i feel like we needed it i i mean
not a lot of times shows don't answer
all the questions about characters
but the fact that like
we're just kind of left in this place of
just
he's doubting his own reality now yeah
it just
i feel like it would have been a
stronger show had he just all we need is
just one line of dialogue just a quick
maybe two sentences
explaining where he came from and why
he's here um
i don't know why that was cut and why
that wasn't included i'm from wyoming
i mean look i know why it was cut and
why it wasn't included because this show
was not about arthur herrera was about
stephen and mark and they wanted to keep
the focus on them and their point of
view and the mystery of they don't
really know what reality is including
harrow uh but if they could say i was
once conscious avatar you could give you
could elaborate a bit more on that i
like a flashback at least that would be
pretty dope i mean a flashback got the
most a flashback you have to shoot all
this other stuff i get it i get it you
don't have time to always shoot a ton of
scenes with a ton of characters but you
can just bring an ethan hawk to the adr
booth and have him say something i
assume half of the dialogue in the show
was looped in after the fact on adr
i'm getting negative here but it's not
negative because i'm mad at the show i
just wanted to see more i want to know
more about it i have follow-ups and
what's more he wants to consume more he
loves it that he wants more on his body
i want to ask you about the ini ad uh it
seems like the indiana at least their
avatars are slaughtered oh are they back
in the overvoid just like scared waiting
waiting for all this to play out what do
you think happened to them now yeah i
think that like the when we saw those
avatars of the any ad um during this
episode it was mostly the avatars
talking and acting and like the the gods
weren't there at all so like now that
these gods avatars are gone the gods are
just chilling in the overvoid they're
just like all right well they're we're
just chilling here and i have a feeling
and this is just a weird punch but the
overvoid actually exists in the quantum
realm um and it could be that city in
the quantum realm because like you know
if we see an ant-man and the wasp that
janet was able to communicate and
possess scott's body from the quantum
realm where she was at so like you know
i think that that science could be in
play here with these gods being in the
overvoid and where that allows them to
possess people from the quantum realm so
i think that yeah but to answer the
question being an editor is probably
like all right well
well that sucks but we we just it's
another avatar gone it's fine we'll just
get another one
just eyes see my thinking is when the
five members of the iniad approached
harrow as as his group walked into the
pyramids i i think that was the gods
because he said you are
judges you're not warriors he was
talking to the gods in that moment i
don't think he was talking to
people because if it was people would be
easy i mean they're all kind of
middle-aged people he's got a huge act
staff to where i don't think there would
even be anything i don't think they
would walk up to him i think these
avatars would be like we're gonna hide
and hopefully get our gods to possess us
i think the the intent of that was he
was able to i mean ahmet is a specific
is a beast he's a warrior
uh and the way that like osiris horus
sets all these others are not so i think
he was able to beat them because of that
uh and i think i i think they have
returned to the overvoid but in that
moment i think those gods were in those
bodies and then he was super injured and
then that was the uh the avatar who was
telling
uh layla what to do um
or maybe it was osiris and it wasn't
really clear when it was just the
avatars or the gods who were talking
right i think that's that's one thing i
wish i saw more in this series it's just
like
i wanted to see what osiris looked like
and what it looked like when osiris was
talking versus when it was the avatar
who talking um but either way this
leaves any ad in the overvoid uh for
uh right for the picking for gore the
god butcher um i don't know if we're
gonna see this in thor 11 thunder
is interested in visiting that corner of
the universe but like it could just be
implied that everybody who was
introduced as a god in the mcu is either
a target or is a victim
of i would love to see kanchu at least
appear in as a cameo with thor 11
thunder at the very least because like i
love conch you a lot be fun um so
overall some final thoughts uh i'm super
grateful for this series i thought oscar
isaac gave an incredible performance as
well as ethan hawk uh this was just a
really really fun series to uh to dive
into every week uh to play along with
the mystery of it i think the
conversations that it uh it led us to
have about mental health and about
egyptology
fascinating i love the world building of
the duat i think uh episode five might
have been my favorite of the uh of the
season i i mean i love me a good walk
down memory lane episode i think in
general the penultimate episodes of a
lot of these series might be my favorite
whichever episode like takes us down
memory lane i love the void episode i
definitely love one division episode
eight i think i love one division
episode eight the most i might
i gotta re-watch monovision okay there's
time before multiverse madness in it
um
but uh
overall i think this is a really really
cool series and i and i i love the
character of moon knight i love what
oscar isaac did and i i want to see him
come back in the mcu to address some of
these like lingering questions we have
about his corner of the world
oh no like i think that this show was
phenomenal in terms of like mostly
because i really like when um movies and
like tv shows like really like
talk about like really important human
things and this episode this whole
series was all about self-love and mark
and steve accepting each other but also
accepting themselves as as people and as
as in being okay with what they've done
and like who they are as people and so
like i really want more projects like
this where like there is this
like bigger
meaning to it and that could mean a lot
to a lot of people and like and again
like with the whole did stuff like i
learned so much about d.i.d from this
entire series and i'm so grateful that
we i i we had this because like in that
the world has this because so many
people are about to learn more about did
and like not have those stupid um
you know stereotypes and like those
those really awkward thing and not right
things about did um floating around as
much and like that's why shows like this
are so important so like i really love
moon knight it was a great show and like
also the egyptian representation
10 out of 10. like you guys did a really
good job with that and i really love
that so
that's that's my thoughts
agreed agreed and we will leave it uh
there for this episode of inside marvel
now empty and i of course will always
come back to have this marvel
conversation every week here on inside
marvel and next week probably gonna be
talking about the biggest questions
coming out of dr strange in the
multiverse of madness so hold on to your
butts don't forget to check out our many
great merch options over at your
rockstarsmerch.com follow me eddie avas
following mastertainment again my easter
egg breakdown coming out later too no
not later today i'm sorry it's coming up
tomorrow it's a busy week guys i gotta
see multiple madness
early i'm trying to get
started on the breakdown early there's
just a lot there's a lot but i'm great
bro i'm grateful to have this stuff to
talk about
um anyway subscribe to inside marvel
wherever get your podcast thank you for
watching later skaters latest games
you